لما نزحنا من اول الحرب نزحنا جيينا على
مدارس لواء بعد فتره حتى اليهود ملناش
واحنا في مدارس لواء وهذه مدارس مدعومه
وور يعني عليها حصانه دوليه
فاليهود اجونا على المدارس فانت شردنا من
المدارس نفسها رحنا على مدارس اوا ثانيه
ونمنا في الشوارع وكان وضعنا صعب كثير
وضعنا مزري زي ما
بكوها الحمد لله والله بقينا احنا في
مدرسه لوجهي خشوا علينا اليهود بالجرافات
ودمروها نا وطلعنا وحاملين ويانا والقناص
من فوقنا طخ اولادنا صغار وحاملين ولا
حاجه طلعنا والحمد لله وانتقلنا هنا رغم
الدمار و كل شي لكن صامدين والمطر هي
علينا ونا بنقفل صامدين والحمد لله ويا رب
نرجع كمان على بيت حنون ونصمت
كمان
وانا كطفل من اطفال
فلسطين بدعو اطفال
العالم بدعو جميع الامم المتحده يعني كل
الامم اللي بتطالب في حقوق الانسان تيجي
تشوف احنا كيف وضعنا احنا قاعدين في ظل
ظروف سقعه فيش ميه لا في كهرباء اطفالنا
مرضوا يعني احنا قاعدين انا بحكي عن نفسي
قاعدين قبالنا جتت مدفونه تحت السيارات
اللي خلفها اليهود لما نكسرها
طعج السيارات وضلوا شهدا تحت مش حدش عارف
يشم المطر غرقنا وفرشنا انت ميه واطفالنا
كلهم معهم بردانين كنا يعني ع انفار يمكن
بس حرمين عنا نزوق
حناف الاد الصغار يدفوا والحمد
لله